ضمن فعاليات موسم الرياض وتحديدا في ونتر
وندر لاند اضيف للمنطقه ملاهي جديده انشطه
اضافيه للاطفال باسم هابي تاون التي
تجذبهم بالفعاليات الحركيه وتكنولوجيه
[موسيقى]
فعاليه جديده تشهدها مناطق موسم الرياض في
نسخته الثالثه منها مدينه السعاده او كما
تعرف بها تاون التي تتوسطه منطقه وينتر
وندر لاند وهي مدينه مخصصه للاطفال
لممارسه الانشطه الحركيه والتكنولوجيا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الان تستطيع ان افرق بينهم هذا توت
والاخرون من المؤكد انه وعمر من هذا الشاب
انت مهند صحيح نعم لانه من صفات المحقق ان
يهدد شراب حسنا
نونو المخصص للاطفال يساعدهم على تنميه
مهاراتهم الحركيه والدهنيه بانشطته
المتنوعه ما بين اللاعب الكره والطبخ وما
بين الرسمي والتلوين
[موسيقى]
قد اقبل الشتاء
الساعه 1:00
فتحت النافذه شتاء شتاء شتاء التجارب
العلميه البسيطه كانت حاضره لتثقيف
الاطفال في مجال العلوم المرحه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بالتسلق للوصول الى القمه ليشعر الاطفال
بالانجاز
[موسيقى]
من الرياض شهد متروك بالعربيه